hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt ich habe heute ein richtig leckeres
herz auf das gericht für euch und zwar
geht es heute ein kartoffelgratin mit
hackfleisch und das geht auch wirklich
ganz schnell das ist ein sehr simples
rezept aber wirklich ein sehr leckeres
rezept was ich ganz gerne über mache
wenn ich ihn nicht so viele stoffe so
richtig viel zu kochen
denn es sei gut und schmeckt gut und
dazu passt einfach ein einfacher salat
einfach einfach und ich werde es noch
sagen ich zeige euch einfach kurz die
zutaten
ich habe jetzt hier fleisch also ihr
könnt auch direkt hackfleisch benutzen
und zwar habe ich jetzt hier 500 gramm
rindfleisch und 500 gramm lammfleisch
ich sage ich da gleich aber was dazu
dann braucht ihr etwas olivenöl eine
zwiebel für die kartoffeln brauchen wir
dann 300 milliliter milch 200 milliliter
sahne ein kilo kartoffeln das war nichts
mehlig kochende die habe ich bereits
geschält eine knoblauchzehe und etwa 150
gramm gouda käse und natürlich brauche
ich später noch ein paar gewürze als
ganzes zum fleisch ich mag ganz gerne
die mischung aus lammfleisch und
rindfleisch und deswegen hole ich mir
ganz gerne dann das fleisch am stück
macht selber mein hackfleisch also mein
papa bringt mit da immer ganz gerne
fleisch mit und dann kann ich das eben
selber verarbeiten und ich brauche jetzt
aber insgesamt nur 500 gramm hackfleisch
ich habe jetzt nur ein bisschen mehr
weil ich den rest und einfach einfrieren
werde man kann aber zum beispiel beim
türkischen metzger auch bereits lamm und
rindfleisch als hackfleisch gemischt
kaufen
aber ich finde so ganz gut weil ich
einfach selber bestimmen kann wie viel
an möchte ich mit drin haben wie viel
sind möchte ich mit drin haben und habe
jetzt dafür beim rindfleisch rinder
als benutzt und beim lammfleisch
lammkeule und ich mache das jetzt
einfach mal ganz gut
und zwar durch das fleisch und in so
portionen gestattet dann kommt es da
oben rein da würde ich auch nicht so
abdrücken sondern lasse einfach das
fleisch von alleine reinfallen und ich
habe vorne jetzt so eine ganz feine
scheibe
also es sollte auf jeden fall das
fleisch mit diesem stück immer an die
öffnung schieben und auf keinen fall mit
den fingern mag ich den finger nicht
reihen aber trotzdem ist hier immer
vorsicht geboten
mit lass ich das jetzt einmal kurz durch
und familie standes hackfleisch
jetzt habe ich das fertige hackfleisch
und wie gesagt hab ich ja nur 500 gramm
davon
deswegen nehme ich jetzt die andere
hälfte die kann ich ein frieren und dann
habe ich einfach wieder hackfleisch auf
vorrat und ich zeige euch einfach mal
wie ich das mache und zwar gebe ich das
in so einem gefrierbeutel immer in so
500 gramm päckchen nämlich nämlich
später einfacher wenn ich das
portionieren möchte
und dann drücke ich das hier schön flach
damit die luft entweicht und zwar hat es
den vorteil dass ich dann im gefrierfach
nicht so viel platz verbraucher und
später hat auch den vorteil beim
auftauen dass es eben viel schneller
auftaut also deswegen mache ich das
jetzt hier immer so ganz schön flach
dann glaube ich dass da oben um da kommt
auch immer so ein verschluss drauf wo
ich dann drauf schreibt hier sitzt lamm
und rind mit drin 500 gramm und daneben
das datum wann ist eingefahren habe und
damit ich einfacher funktionieren kann
später und wenn ich mal einfach weniger
brauche nämlich immer so ein teil karte
oder an die rückseite von dem messer
funktioniert es jetzt und zwar in
ungefähr 5 gleich große stücke
also erstmal hier die mitte markieren
und dann noch mal so durch die hälfte
dann weiß ich nämlich später beim
auftauen das einfach so ein stück 50
gramm hat und je nachdem wie viel ich
brauch kann ich mir dann einfach die
menge herausnehmen und auftauen lassen
und so kommt es jetzt einfach kurz in
gefahr als nächstes habe ich jetzt hier
immer eine pfanne bereits gerichtet da
gebe ich jetzt einen esslöffel olivenöl
rein
und da kommt ihr fleisch direkt mit dazu
und wird da eben schön angebraten
und ich werde jetzt hier in der
zwischenzeit schon mal die zwiebel fein
hacken
jetzt gebe ich da noch die zwiebeln mit
dazu und die werden dann mit gebraten
und zwar so lange bis es hackfleisch
eben krümelig wird und die zwiebeln
weich werden
und ich werde in der zwischenzeit schon
mal die kartoffel nehmen und halbieren
und daneben in dünne scheiben schneiden
hackfleisch ab jetzt schon auf die seite
genommen das ist jetzt fertig und jetzt
geb ich sahne und münchen einen topf und
zwar wird es jetzt die soße da kommen
auch direkt die kartoffel mit rein
dann gebe ich da direkt muskat mit rein
frisch gerieben etwas fester und einen
teelöffel salz oder einkaufen
und das lasse ich jetzt ganz kurz
aufkochen
und in der zwischenzeit kann ich hier
drüben schon mal die knoblauchzehe klein
schneiden und die kommt dann mit zu den
kartoffeln
die kartoffeln dürften jetzt einmal ganz
kurz aufkochen
jetzt habe ich sie auch direkt vom herd
wieder runter genommen die fülle ich
jetzt immer eine vorbereitete
auflaufform die habe ich jetzt bereits
eingefettet damit auch später nichts
dran kleben bleibt
das wird jetzt hier drin schön verteilt
jetzt kann ich hier drüben das
hackfleisch noch fertig würzen und zwar
kommt da jetzt ein halber teelöffel salz
rhein eine gute prise pfeffer
titel teelöffel kreuzkümmel das nehme
ich halt immer ganz gerne wenn ich was
mit lamm zubereitet und so eine gute
prise chili
und jetzt kommen diese hackfleisch
mischung einfach auf die kartoffel mit
drauf und es gibt halt dem gericht so
diese würze aber falls jetzt sagt ich
möchte ein kartoffelgratin machen was
vegetarisch isst dann lasst einfach den
teil mit dem hackfleisch weg und habe
auch ein richtig leckeres würziges
kartoffel katar
jetzt noch schön darüber verteilen
jetzt kommt noch der käse darüber den
habe ich jetzt auch bereits gegeben
und so kommt das kartoffelgratin jetzt
in den vorgeheizten backofen bei 220
grad ober und unterhitze für etwa 25
minuten und danach was ich es ganz kurz
abkühlen und zeigt euch dann nichts aus
und nicht mit das kartoffelgratin ist
jetzt fertig und ich habe es jetzt so
etwa zehn minuten abkühlen lassen damit
man sich beim essen jetzt nicht zu sehr
verbrennen mit schlichtes menschen
stücke vielleicht zu groß
die menge reicht übrigens auch für etwa
vier personen
und dann kann man das hier schön
anrichten und dazu würde ich jetzt auch
noch einen salat machen also den mache
ich jetzt gleich dem rad kommt nämlich
auch gleich von der arbeit damit wir das
gleich zusammen essen können
ich finde da passt super gemischt grüner
salat dazu also im grünen gemüse salat
mit karotten und salat und vielleicht
seinen senf dressing und auf jeden fall
finde ich dass dieses rezept sehr würzig
schmeckt und ihr könnt auch zum beispiel
abwandeln in dem ihr noch ein bisschen
gemüse mit fleisch gibt also das können
da gerne auch machen zum beispiel ein
paar champignons bin ich ganz lecker
habe ich jetzt heute aber weggelassen
einfach weil ich heute nur lust auf
fleisch und kartoffeln hatte und wenn
ihr das rezept nach machen wollt dann
geht einfach auf meinem blog auf salehs
- blog.de da gibt's noch mal die genauen
zutaten und ich wünsche euch ganz viel
spaß beim nachmachen und einen guten
appetit bis dann tschüss